Jason can you tell us how you booked
your first paid acting job that would be
the secret life of the american teenager
it was when my dad was in the show and
brenda hampton who created it she asked
my dad do you have any kids do they act
and he said yes my son acts and she says
well would he like to be on the show he
says well I mean you'd like that but I
don't want you to just give him apart I
want you to see him so she invited me to
the table read and I read for this part
Joe Hampton nice little last name there
and she liked me and so she brought me
on and so the casting was in LA or New
York it was in Los Angeles I didn't live
in New York until after college okay and
you were what 16 when this yeah I think
I was i think it was 16 i think it was
near the end of my sophomore year so you
were attending high school mm-hmm and um
how did that work I mean it was how many
episodes were you in that you had to
miss school or maybe didn't miss school
I think I did about I think I did like
12 episodes total and that was over the
course of a few years he wasn't a
recurring recurring character he'd pop
up every now and again like a little
cameo and I and I never had to shoot
more than one or two days so if I did
miss a day of school it would just be
one day okay how did that feel to be
paid as an actor because so many actors
talk about they get to a point where
they love doing the work they don't mind
doing free work but after a while they
really feel like it's time that I'm paid
well it felt pretty good because i
hadn't i had i was still in high school
so I hadn't really been doing the whole
audition grind or anything like that I
just been in school plays and local
theater and so I didn't know the feeling
of doing 50 auditions without getting
anything and so it felt nice it felt
nice to be on a set I thought it was
educational to see what it's like and
get a feeling for the air it also made
me realize that a hell of a lot of work
to do you know because you really do
have to be on your game when you're
doing a professional set so what was
that first day like like what was your
call time and
then what was that really make 630 630
ok and you remember how you felt like
walking on set that day i felt good i
felt cautious i just i was trying to see
what this was because I loved film and
TV sup lump so much will mostly film and
so I i was i was once set and i thought
well this is it this is this is how you
do it you know it's not just like a play
or you just get to kind of do a lot of
work by yourself and just work with
people in a small space like it just i
figured out very quickly that people are
there just to do a job they know what
they're going to do and it's an actor
you show up when a lot of the work has
already been done and you're giving a
call and you just kind of show up and
deliver right then and at least as it
especially the day player maybe if
you're a lead you get a little bit more
pre-production time but as a day player
you just show up right so you had not
attended lamba yet of course because
you're in high school so then with the
blocking what was that like I'm not too
familiar with blocking so can you tell
me walking yeah yeah well it's just a
lot of complicated shots it would just
me be standing in a hall talking to
people in the school hall so you know
the cameras they're trying to get a
certain shot and you gotta be in the
cinematographers already work for the
director to figure out the framing so
they have these marks on the ground like
this tape you got to find your mark for
a certain line or a certain segment of
the action and you got to hit that mark
while doing what you need to do like
whether you're delivering a liar
performing an action like a physical
action and you got to hit it and but
still make it spontaneous and you have
it have intention in that moment without
making it look rehearse so do you
remember when it was your scene and they
called action like how much did you feel
in the moment how scary was it or
exhilarating uh it was exciting and a
little scary yeah I would imagine uh I
mean it was a lot of fun to do was a fun
oh and the people and they were really
nice I don't know if I was fully
comfortable yet to be fully present I
had tried but I think it's it takes a
lot to get out of your head and get into
your body it takes a lot of confidence
right so were you cognizant of that at
that time that that there was such a
thing as being present as an actor or
mean at 16 yeah something you were aware
of her I was aware of it I don't know
what it I don't think I knew how it felt
fully it's hard to do I think as a young
actor you see all these grades and you
see the result of the performances and
you want so badly to to have that result
and be that great and the funny thing is
is like when you try to make that result
happens happen that's usually what makes
you tense and not in the moment right
and so ye it takes I think it takes a
while for certain people to learn that
you just gotta let go and I mean you
gotta do your preparation in order to
let go you can't just walk up and
improvise you got to really know what
you're doing and then the essence of
your character and and and kind of
yourself and the actions but Jason you
said something I think I heard you say
you still had to get your game up I'm
sorry if I'm paraphrasing but what was
it that you felt you were off about or
that you need to improve on and how have
you worked through that hmm for that
role well uh I felt like I was just a
talking head like I think there's a
feeling that matters described where
your there's one part of you that's
outside of yourself it's aware of what
you're doing but then there's another
part which is just there and in that
moment and it almost feels like there's
some deeper part of you that's doing the
work and that's performing the actions
and it's like you're in like an almost
like another self and I didn't have
it's hard to explain you know I guess I
think I think people try to over
intellectualize acting a lot and you
need technique for sure but I think when
you over intellectualize acting and try
to put a lot of specific when I got to
be specific as an actor but when you try
to be a fully I'm trying to think of the
best way to describe this I think if my
dad has a saying if you can remember
exactly how you did then it probably
wasn't any good because you were
probably too concerned about how you
were doing it rather than just doing it
right there interesting so I got that I
was aware of that that I was not letting
go and just losing myself in that moment
and just I think that takes confidence
and a lot of being in touch with
yourself and who you are do you think
because it mattered so much that was
your first job and you know you're going
to be on set with your dad too so maybe
you want to please him but it just
mattered so much it was hard to really
be in the moment that sounds like yeah
and I just think you know as a teenager
you don't really know who you are yet
and you're just starting to figure out
what this whole acting thing is I think
it's a teenager's a hard time to be an
actor because when you're a child you're
quite free you know kids they have a lot
of impulses and they don't and I that
they don't censor themselves you know
they're very close to who they are and
like they I don't think there is self
aware of their habits or insecure and I
think there's a stereotype that you know
that kid actors aren't good I don't
think that's true i think they're only
not good if you try to make them act or
if you'd write them as little adults
because kids are so they're so
spontaneous and they're so impulsive and
they're so connected to their body and
who they are if you ever watch the
audition video for et the kid who plays
Elliot and like it Steven Spielberg's in
a room with him and that's how you
direct a child actor if you watch that
that videoed awful looked at a visit on
YouTube mm-hmm oh great yeah that sounds
good what was it the way Spielberg
directed him that's fascinating uh been
a while since I've seen it he didn't try
to make him give these results he
said you know like this is what's
happening to you and you know your
friend they're gonna take him away you
just talk to him like a kid you just
understood what kids want you know
rather than trying to tell he wasn't
telling him like me cute like you know
be the angry or like be he was just he
was just telling I'm like this is what's
happening to your friend you know and if
they take him away then you won't have
your friend anymore and you know justice
just give it to me and like I think
something like that I know that's Justin
I think I read that you said you like
playing characters that are outsiders
mm-hmm why uh I think it's an
interesting perspective to work with I
mean Outsiders is a broad term so that
could mean a lot but I like playing
characters that challenge people's
perceptions because I think we live in a
world where so much of our perception is
given to it for us this given is given
to us by other people you know it's such
a cliché hipster thing to say but it's
true that you know we're exposed to
commercials all the time and and social
media posts and we tend to surround are
our friends list on social media with
people who agree with us and and you
know a lot of the movies we watch are
made by the same people and controlled
by the same companies and they follow
trends and we're just weirdest exposed
to so much media betraying a certain
lifestyle and you can and in today's age
you can choose to surround yourself with
media that that reflects what you find
comfortable and that i think it's it's
very easy to become very locked and what
you believe and so i really like playing
outsiders because i think it challenges
people's perceptions on what what is
normal or what what life god what life
means that such it no no I there's
there's a gentleman that wrote a book I
think in the 50s about the notion of the
outsider and and other people's big
people's perceptions the fear some
people have
of the outsider and the fascination and
also the loneliness and isolation of
that outsider and I forgive me I at the
name of the book and the writer is
escaping me but I think it's a
fascinating thing especially now because
we're kind of afraid of anything that's
different and we're taught to fear who
are some of your favorite outsider
characters and why what do you like well
you know there's Travis Bickle of course
I think the ultimate outsider movie
character like not a good man by most
definitions but I find him interesting
because it's easy to just say oh he's
just a crazy guy but you know it's like
he I think that that characters a
reflection of a society that produced
him you know it's like imagine that you
live in that city at that time and here
in this car and you're just separated
from the city by glass and metal and
you're driving passing we talked about
you know the pimps and the hustlers and
all these different people and you know
I think about the people again to his
cab late at night you know I like
business men cheating on their wives
with different girls or like you know
there's that one character who's the
opposite of the husband trying to find
his wife he says I'm gonna shoot her in
the fate in the he says I'm gonna
shoot her in the of the 44 Magnum
pistol and you know I lives in this
right little apartment by himself and
this warming hive of people and and I
you know he doesn't have a lot of money
so he you know he goes to like those
pornographic movie houses and he takes
that girl to that pornographic movie
house and it sags I think he actually in
his mind thought it was a good idea for
a date I think because I like how it
doesn't really tell you a lot about his
past he says he's a Vietnam vet some
people wonder whether he is the
screenwriter says that he is yeah and I
think it's easy just look at him as this
crazy person but you gotta ask like when
my just a few steps away from being
Travis Bickle like what if I was put
alone an apartment in a ratty part
for that amount of time and right if I
was cut off from people and fed scene
but he'd seen so is it is it fascinating
to see someone that the masses would say
they're weird or they're bad but if you
really is bad i'm not saying you sure
sure but but maybe there's others in
varying degrees where if you sort of
looked at the timeline of their life you
could see why they got to that point and
maybe have more empathy but instead most
people put up the shield of fear and
you're more fascinated by peeling back
those layers yeah yeah you know it's
like I am and not just that type of
outside or different outsiders to but I
guess I'm a type of guy who lets say if
someone gets bitten by a rabid dog most
people tend to feel bad for the guy and
I feel bad for the guy to it'll get me
wrong but I also tend to feel bad for
the rabid dog because they're a verte
they're very they're very few genuine
sociopaths in the world like people who
are just born with no morality
whatsoever you know and i think it's
it's hard to because i think you know
i'm not i wouldn't go as far as to say
that i'm a biological determinist i
wouldn't go that far but i think at the
end of the day we are physical systems
where we're a collection of cells and
like if I touched like a hot poker that
is a bunch of molecules and energies it
sends a reaction to these physical cells
you know this whole universe we live in
is a physical universe it's full of
actions and reactions and you know we
are bana milles and I think people don't
like being told that their animals
because it ruins their kind of illusions
of being this effervescent spirit that's
in complete control of their life you
know like I am a individual and I
control my destiny and like you do I
don't think you can control your destiny
nearly as well unless you're very aware
of your base kind of cognitive biases
and your base instincts you know like
and I think depending on the physical
environment that you're in you know
people react to that so I think it we
gotta be aware of this and really be
aware of like the type of media we
consume or the tie
message that we're sending and and I
just think that's the only way that we
can really make people change or is if
we're aware of what created them you
know because I think people like to
treat these people like bogeyman like
it's easy to treat a suicide bomber like
just some crazy person who hates people
and yeah maybe he hates people he's a
bad guy he's a bad guy but a lot but
maybe but you know you got to look back
and if this many people are are creating
these actions and doing what they do
that that are willing to give up their
lives what they believe is a cause
obviously something has put them into a
rather desperate position so we got to
examine what caused that situation in
the first place rather than just
treating it like a like a thing like
something that can be they we treat evil
like it's just this thing that can be
killed we can just make it go away by
killing it so rather than changing the
circumstances that bring it about do you
think people can write a script for
their own life and and become and this
is such like a cliche but do we
determine our own fate and in doing that
can you somehow related to acting I
think we can if you try to make yourself
aware like really study you know study
all sorts of different areas you know
study psychology but then again study
the different branches and and see the
different ideas but not just psychology
or like you know study history to see
what people have done and see what the
results of that word see different
perspectives not just one and again I
think this be aware of the fact that you
are a little creature you know that is
given certain instincts by what you were
exposed to and it's think question
yourself you know I mean be confident
yourself but question yourself and I
think in the way that that relates to
acting you always gotta be
perfectly aware of the physical reality
of your character I don't think that
necessarily means like what's your
characters favorite color or like you
know what was your character's mom like
but if it's in the script I get they
live in a house and it says their houses
like this well what does that say about
them you know like if they if they if
they go to their like a construction
worker well what are the physical
realities of being a construction worker
you know and how does that relate to
what the point of the story is you know
like because writer chose that for a
reason to make them a construction
worker so how does that relate to the
point that they're trying to make Jason
who do you think should get into acting
and who do you think maybe acting might
not be for huh well uh I think acting's
for people who want to learn more about
how people work and who want to tell
stories and who don't mind making
themselves look ridiculous oh man that's
exacting can be so many things and
there's so many stories that we can tell
I mean I think I think acting is just a
way to figure out what motivates people
and it's a way to understand why we tell
the stories that we tell because we've
been selling stories for thousands of
years and you know we think about how
many movies come out of a year and how
many TV shows come out of a year and and
and how many well I wish there were more
plays that came out of a year but so the
fact that we still watched so many
movies and devote so much time the
television and then books and all these
things and says that stories are
obviously important you know I think
people do like to treat them as just
disposable and escape I think the type
of escape that you go to says a lot
about what you want and the characters
who I that people identify with says a
lot so I think if you want to figure out
what makes people tick but also learn
more about yourself by discovering what
you relate to with the character but you
don't really do with the character and
what you can portray then I think
acting's for you I think if you if
you're willing to injure hundreds of
auditions without getting anything and
devote a lot of time to examining
yourself and your have
it's in your essence and seeing like how
it is you portray yourself then yeah I
think it's for you if you like to set
you feel like playing pretend it's for
you if it's not for you let me obviously
we need people make the world run we
ditch diggers and we need fire men and
we need furniture builders and we need
plumbers and we need want to make stuff
happen like that in a very in a very
visible way like here's this table and I
make this table then acting is not for
you if you uh I don't know it's hard to
really say I mean if you don't want to
be exposed like that then acting is not
for you if you don't want to dress up in
a silly costume then acting's not for
you how did you know it was for you was
there was there a moment I mean you know
before your role on the secret life of
an american teenager did you see
something else or experience another
movie set something where you thought I
think this is something that I'm willing
to go through the good times in the bad
whatever happens with it well I went to
an acting camp called the Columbia Gorge
School of Theatre for seven straight
summers from when I was 11 till I was 17
oh and it was a place where a lot of
people from various ages from toddlers
to teenagers came and we had a couple
movement teachers and a dance teacher in
a music teacher every year and jesse was
the acting teacher in the head of the
camp and it was up in Washington State
just in the middle of nowhere in the
mountains and a lot of weird kooky crazy
people were there with different
perspectives and it was a place where
you could be whoever you wanted to be
which I liked in which i like about
acting too i think you can be whoever
you want to be whether you're
christopher walken nur or chris
hemsworth you can be whoever you want to
be and it's a place for everybody in
acting and I figure that out at sea GST
because Jesse wanted to make sure
there's a place for everyone at sea GST
as long as you respect at each other and
he got along so that really made me want
to act and I think I just figured out
again like I said I figured
how people worked through acting and in
terms of what like what moods I'm
curious what does that mean what mood
moved people what motivated people our
secrets our desires what we fantasize
about in the actions that we choose to
take I remember i saw the aviator with
Leonardo DiCaprio was Howard Hughes and
I was I think 13 almost no I was 12
almost 13 when I saw that film which is
a ver adult film but I just remembered
being intrigued by this man who had all
these these visions of what he wanted
and he was willing to do anything to do
and he challenged people and he was so
charismatic but he also was quite quite
affected in his mind you know he had
obsessive compulsive and could be quite
neurotic and I remember being so I just
south of I member that was the first
time ever really really wondered how an
actor did that and I thought what did he
have to do to betray all these ticks and
all these different stages of this
character and all these different sides
to him and then how did he do that on
camera and what do you have to do to
prepare for that and then and I was just
kind of fascinated by this outsider man
and I was kind of fascinated by how cuz
you know DiCaprio he doesn't really look
a lot like the real Howard Hughes Howard
Hughes was quite a tall imposing man you
had quite a rugged heavy face when he
was young and Howard Hughes is not that
Caprio is quite he's more youthful and
he's kind of more slender and he's got
more of a youthful face but I thought he
I believe the ambition that he had and
the kind of the fragility underneath the
bravado particularly the seam he's a
Katharine Hepburn's house you know Cate
Blanchett's Hepburn and all this old
money he's just a boy from Texas who got
money and i think they say something
like we don't care about money here and
he says and he just kind of looking down
he can't even look him in the eye he's
his billionaire he says
no that's because for you money has
never been an object and i just
remembered i just kind of yeah being
like that struck something in me when he
just kind of was not a place at the
dinner table is it helpful for someone
to say oh you're an actor you know who
you look just like and then you're like
well even if it's a compliment or maybe
someone you're thinking okay whatever
but do you feel that that's helpful for
the outside world to tell an actor that
they look just like another actor um I
mean I think it is in a way as much as a
lot of actors are insecure about that uh
because you know you do have to know how
people perceive you it doesn't mean you
have to try to pander to what people
want from you because I do think as an
actor it's important to take chances and
take risks and you know like follow your
instincts but at the same time what you
have to I think you have to know how
people perceive you before you try and
challenge legs if you don't know how to
perceive you how are you going to
challenge that you know like you gotta
you gotta because I've been told I look
like Robert Pattinson whether that's a
good or a bad thing you I think it's
important to know that because if you
don't know you know that's a lot of talk
about type in Hollywood right and I
think it can be quite limiting but even
so we still have to be aware of it sore
because I mean if you're a heavyset man
you want to be James Bond and you think
you can change that and you think you
can challenge people's perception of
change bond go ahead but in order to do
that you have to know that people will
not look at you and think that you're
James Bond so so you have to be aware of
your type before you challenge your type
you do have to be aware of how people
perceive you it's like they don't say
you can break the rules but you have to
know the rules before you break them so
you don't even necessarily have to
follow the rules but you have to know
them right or in order to change the
system you have to be part of the system
but maybe that's a different go outside
yeah yeah I think in a way yeah so do
you remember when a casting director or
someone said oh this is your type and
how did you feel about it and
did you want to challenge it uh me
robert pattinson that's not a bad that's
not a bad no I uh I think when did
people start saying that to me I think
like junior high school already people
were saying that about me hmm uh and I
can see that yeah but you still have
your own look but did you did you feel I
want to be chasing I don't want it Mei I
think yeah I think I felt that I had
some people say I look like Brando which
didn't bother me one bit sure no yeah
yeah and so I was aware of that and i
think it was i was aware that with my
look and with my build and with my
height that I think people can see me as
a kind of a young fresh face California
guy which is fine you can't be too picky
as a young person but I wanted to kind
of break that in order to challenge that
you really gotta know what you're doing
as you really got to be good if you're
going to break people's perception of
your physical look if you really got to
bring that essence of what you want with
you and trying to think of what else
could set people that set a look like
Brando that at drama school I don't
think they cast me as Outsiders very
often which disappointed me I must admit
like right the cast me has a lot of
kings and princes which is fine i was
thinking myself i don't really know if
that's me unless it's a weird king like
a king george the third type of thing so
you knew that people considered you
extremely attractive and you were okay
would guess okay well but but you wanted
something with maybe more depth to it
that wasn't just like oh he's a pretty
boy you wanted something that will have
maybe a dark side or a complicated side
too yeah it's not that attractive can't
be have depth to it but i like to Ryan
Gosling is an actor who really speaks to
me he's very good-looking he's very
handsome but up until a couple films
recently he didn't he never chose
typical leading-man roles I mean there
was a notebook but eat when he was yet
but even then with the notebook he
doesn't really play it like a typical
handsome guy you can tell he's a bit of
a sensitive kind of person and there's a
little bit of like kind of the it's I
think something is trying to prove
that character and then but if you look
at after the notebook you know because
he could have just been this this
romantic leading man but he chose films
like half nelson repaid a coke addicted
teacher Lars and the real girl like
because he's this beautiful man but he
he wears ugly sweaters in that movie and
like stupid d knees and he he's so
disconnected that he has a sex doll that
he marries and is in love with right and
you know or or uh blue Alan oh sorry
yeah but Valentine he's a just as this
working-class dude just a product of
divorce and and I think he just really
he challenges tight for sure and and
drive as well he's just this autistic
seeming driver right so when you were
told what your type was did you find
different ways where you thought okay
I'd like to work around it when I do an
audition or even what I'm cast for I
want to have my own way about it that's
not just this one dimensional pretty
character but I want to have it be
complicated layers where you go there's
a backstory here that brought that
person to be who they are and I I want
to be the one that finds out yeah I mean
is I didn't have too many auditions in
high school I guess in New York I just
try to play it the best I can like I
don't know I think I'd actually think
there is a danger in trying because as
an actor you got to make choices but
there's a danger and kind of over
intellectualizing what you're doing too
much and kind of saying I need this
result to happen or I want this result
to happen or or you have a fixed idea of
what a character is supposed to be I
mean you can play with it and you can
see what the essence of the character is
and what part of the story the character
is at and then you can try different
things like I imagine this characters a
bit like a panther maybe that's how he
moves or maybe this care this characters
like like that boisterous Texas man i
saw the bar the other night but actually
i think you can
get to cut up and backstory I mean I
think there are some decisions that you
have to make but like I think so many
people try to think like what's this
characters favorite color or like you
know what's like like what what made him
cry is a kid and I think like if it's
hinted at in the script or if it's
important then yeah maybe decide that
but I think if it's if you're just
making stuff up I think you can kind of
get caught up in your own head and you
can kind of hypnotize yourself or your
ear it's just all just psychology that
just it's just things you made up rather
than just something that's quite
tangible that's kind of immediate like a
like a set like the whole Panther thing
it's like you know there's a very simple
and recognizable essence to a panther
you know are like a chicken or whatever
you think your character is or so I
guess when I look at the audition like I
know that I'm different and I know that
I don't express emotion or intention in
a way that most people do so and I have
to be aware of that let's say if I'm
playing a a clean-cut business manda I
have to change my essence but at the end
of the day I know that it's just me so I
think that'll come across give me an
example of a human Panther if you were a
man in a suit or whatever your attire is
what camp or a human Panther in some
sense good example uh hmm I think
because they're very sleek to the way
they move I forgot to be really really
specific on this they're calculating
I'll tell you what it's not a Michael
Crawford as the original fan of the
Opera if you watch the way he moved i
wasn't born at that time but i seen
videos of him and have talked to people
who watched it he moved almost like a
panther every move that he made was so
fluid and so calculated and he was just
so it's like every muscle in his body
was just so kind of focused on what was
in front of him and he actually he wore
very small shoes were too tight for him
so every step he had to take had to be
very delicate and very precise a very
ginger because that his shoes were so
tight and he chose to do that to make
himself move more you know more
cautiously so he didn't have to act it
interesting do you study a lot of old
movies oh yeah hell hell yeah I think I
think young actors don't watch nearly
enough old performances because they are
given this idea that it's dated and yeah
maybe some things are different but I
think there's a lot you can learn from
old actors even if the style is
different you can adjust it but yeah I
watched a lot of old movies what Brando
yeah anyone else James Dean yeah Dean is
great and I think he yeah Dean's great I
think he had a few flaws but he's that
he's got great very interesting
physicality everything he does is so
reflexive and so spontaneous and he's
just so supple you know brando had a
very much of attention about him and
dean was much more kind of flowing Henry
Fonda is a favorite of mine an old
favorite it's very unaffected any older
actor that was also an outsider uh well
Dean you know he was a moody teenager
and this kind of the guy just felt very
disconnected from where he was like
that's why I think rebel people still
look at that image of rebel without a
cause because he's just a teenager
doesn't know what he wants to do with
his life and doesn't feel like he has
any role models and Robert Mitchum was
quite an outsider you know he was a
first actor arrested for smoking pot if
I mean if you look at night of the
hunter that's such a strange performance
which i think is why it holds up now was
weird then and it's still weird now so
Robert Mitchum is definitely an outsider
actor I think a female actress I mean I
know a Marilyn Monroe definitely had a
sort of a bunny like facade but I think
she was very bright and intense no yeah
she yes great movement my God look at
her hips like you know she's got the
great song the hips with Maryland the
way she moves them a little little more
recent but I think spacek might be
my favorite actress she's got a very
unique lot of grace about spacek I
think a lot of understanding look at
badlands you know
doesn't even feel like a performance
chasin you did an interview and you
mentioned something to the effect of
I've learned that this industry is very
hard you have a lot of people demanding
a lot of things from you and not
everything is going to go your way no
matter how many hours you put into it do
you still feel this way oh yeah for sure
I think you kind of never stopped
feeling that way even if you do get big
no matter how big you are at the end of
the day you are part of a collaborative
medium and there are a lot of people in
this industry despite a lot of people
but it's also quite small everybody
knows each other so you know you just
got to realize that you're a part of the
process and even as it even if you're a
director is controlling it all you still
got producers to attend to and you can
argue with them for sure does doesn't
mean you have to take everything lying
down the end of the day you know I think
you do have to be a little Buddhist and
be like you know this is just a part of
life and I can't control everything and
you got as much passion as you you have
to be and be involved you also got a
distance yourself from it it's too shall
pass interesting like a sins yeah yeah
there is in person how do you do that
how do you how do you care about it but
at the same time I mean I hear that and
I think it's very tough for people
whatever pursued it is to not get so
wrapped up even though that can be their
downfall i get it i mean i haven't fully
figured it out and it takes a long way
to go I think you just you got to be
professional on the one hand you know
you can challenge people and you can
definitely break the rules if you know
how to do them in a way that does not
anger people in a way that's like if I'd
say if you break the rules you gotta
break them you and less like if you're
absolutely sure that someone will be
like I really like that you did that and
even I don't know it's hard especially
when you're starting out and I guess I
would just say it's not it's about the
craft but I think you just got to
realize that it's not about
quote-unquote being good which sounds
counterproductive if you're going to
work hard I think if you try to make
something be good we're trying to make
something happen and then that's what
kill you that's what will hold you back
you know and I think you just got to it
and it's got to realize that you're not
bigger than life you know like they're
like I said earlier there are other
people and you just have to it they take
chances take risks maybe even break the
rules every now and again but you got to
realize that you you got to humble
yourself you know and realize that you
are not everything and that you're not
entitled to anything unless you do good
work and even if you do could do good
work that doesn't mean you're entitled
to everything so keeping that thought
that you want something IE a certain
part and let's say you audition and you
almost get it but you don't get it how
do you live with that and you just
realize that's part of it but what do
you take yourself through to do Lau
yourself to kind of feel down and then
come back out yeah well if you almost
get it that means they like you you know
that means that they saw something in
you so if you almost get it but don't
they're almost certainly going to call
you back for something and you know
maybe just uh in the future just like
give them a little letter to Sir message
if say like I enjoyed coming in for you
and you know i'm just i'm doing this at
the minute if you're doing something
else and you know maybe they'll come and
see you again and yeah just realize that
you gotta do this and you know you got
to let them see you act and just kind of
move on to the next one keep working you
grew up in Los Angeles right agoura
hills the quarry house okay like you you
go on up Malibu and you just passed it
and you go through the canyon so right
when you go out the canyon that's a gora
gora okay but you live in New York now
so you went away to school at lambda in
the UK and then you decided at some
point to pursue acting in your life in
New York what was behind that choice I
think I still wanted to see more of the
world before I went back to LA put a few
more notches on my belt New York's
justice city have always wanted to live
in I saw it in movies growing up and
such a romanticized city and
I just wanted to do more of my craft
they're not that there's not craft in LA
but I really wanted to challenge myself
and and do some more plays as well as
maybe audition for films and because
they have film a TV in New York but they
have a lot of theater so I think there's
a lot of stuff that you would not be
able to do in Los Angeles I just think
it's a good way to get experience and
just get stripes what was the day like
when you made that decision I think I
want to go to New York that was shortly
after I finished school I think it was
when because I was an American student
and all graduating American students
whether you're on three year course a
two-year course of the one-year course
do an American showcase in New York and
in LA and when I was in New York it was
different and I thought I think I want
to try new york just uh I like the
hustle and bustle I was like I'm just
want to try it right and there's maybe
more of an upfront it's more raw more
upfront more yeah yeah I think so and
maybe did you did you find that a little
bit exotic I mean having the la's you
know pretty smiles and they you know
they don't want hurt anyone's feelings
but seems like New York it's almost
better to know up front well something
is uh huh yeah I don't know if I'm
saying that correct no I did you mhm so
was to for you was that refreshing that
it's just more this is how it is and
we're not gonna sugarcoat it but then
there's no pretenses about yeah I like
that in New York to be fair a lot of
people audition when you're done with
the audition they won't even talk to you
they'll just say you know thanks thanks
for having you you know so but I think
people there in general or more upfront
I think people there are more devoted to
like auditioning a lot and taking
classes and not just wanting to be
famous because if you're in New York
you're not going to get famous for very
long time if you get famous at all I
mean same thing in Los Angeles but I
feel like especially in New York yes I
think you have to be there for a long
time before you start getting stuff
unless you're like a dynamite dynamite
actor hmm
I'm not that good well why don't you
think you're there yet hmm it's gotta do
more okay yeah just gotta find myself
and just be confident in my body and who
I am take some people are with others
you know is that something you were self
aware of or did someone tell you did a
casting director kind of I just think it
at it lambda you know it cut me down a
notch cuz I not that didn't know it was
good but I just realized that you know
like you're not going to have people
raving about you right away you really
got to put in these hours and you really
gotta find yourself because I kind of
felt like people didn't always
necessarily I don't know if they
necessarily got who I was as an actor
what I was trying to do I mean I still
learned a lot don't get me wrong I had
great teachers there and I made great
friends but I kind of felt like I was
like damn I don't know if I really know
my technique yet I know what I want and
what I believe I still got to figure out
how I do what I do you know so I just
think that uh I don't know you know some
people it just takes a while just kind
of be comfortable and know what they're
doing I think sanford meisner once said
it takes 20 years to make an actor I
understand you are a poet and you enjoy
poetry is there a poem by a poet that
you admire that describes your life is
an actor hmm Oh whether it's struggle
whether it's fun whether it's
interesting fascinating not a poem about
acting but we're in general I myself the
Walt Whitman poem which is just about
America and about all the different
elements like I think that's a poem that
I really related to because he tried to
see everything he tried to see the
animals we saw the plants he saw the
human body he saw the politician he saw
the all the different workers in the
city he saw the cities and saw the
planes he saw the different parts of
America he saw that was the poet's job
to bring all these different elements
both the physical the spiritual the
emotional the personal the public
and bring them all together and express
the meaning of those and like the
essence of those and our perception of
those and it was his job to communicate
that so I think he was trying to be
aware of everything and how it all
relates and so I think that resonated
with me as an actor because he got to be
aware of it all at least try to you
won't know everything and if you think
that then you're gonna stop progressing
but you always got to try you know when
he say something like sorry about how
he's at the Opera House he says that
like the I'm not quoting directly but
the voice of the soprano like brings me
convulsions like the climax of my love
grip look and I was like damn and that
guy that's a cool way of looking at the
world that guy so in the end of opera
and he's just so into the the the the
product of this woman and the writing in
the and the the house at all these
people are watching it in that guy
literally is coming on life why Walt
Whitman though like these are there
other poems what is it about his being
so aware like this watcher uh is he also
an outsider but he was yeah for sure I
mean he used free verse and there's so
much more wild and loose and not as
tight and concise as the British poetry
and even the American poets ended the
right in the bridge tradition you know
like there would be a certain number of
beats for every line and they there be
rhyming and you know you had like a very
specific point that you had to make in a
very kind of like grounded and
controlled framework and Walt Whitman
just cut it loose so he made his own
meter and he made his own verse lines
and he just like through every good
sounding word in there he could find
this is just something shaggy and
untamed about his poems that I love
something wild and I control which is
like America at that time like this he's
a product of all like these people that
going out west and these people like
making all these new factories like
people cutting down trees at North like
all these people just scrambling like
make something out of this land and you
know he he was he saw the Civil War its
of the nation nearly tear itself apart
they saw you all these different people
these Irish people and French people in
English people and black people in
native
Americans and and so there's just he's
just wildly even says something like I
shake my wild locks at the Sun and and
yeah he was his poetry was so sexual to
a lot of it which shocked and offended
many many people is that what you want
to play a character that's very raw
that's very sort of untamed some of them
yeah I mean there's a lot of different
characters I want to play not just
outsiders but right I'd love to play a
character like that it sucks there was
actually a play in New York that I
wanted to audition for so badly but it
was Walt Whitman in his 30s oh I was too
young I think it was caught what was it
it was uh it was like Emily Dickinson
paranormal investigator just about a
version of Emily Dickinson that was a
paranormal investigator and their
version of walt whitman it said think of
like a young dracula someone who was
willing to do anything to get what he
wants and he sells his soul and i was
like damn i wish i could play that
version of walt whitman so you're in the
movie hate crime which you play opposite
jordan saloon yeah right and i know your
dad's also in the film we talked to
Jordan via a podcast interview last week
so he's based in the south and he was
telling us that part of his business
strategy is an actor is to just really
stay in the south and work on
productions that are happening there and
he felt that he was great as a regional
actor I'm wondering about your strategy
I know you're in New York and I know
there's plenty of opportunity there do
you think there are enough acting jobs
to go around in in I know with Louisiana
I think your dad studios are there
Atlanta there's also South Carolina do
you think that that's a good strategy
for people oh yeah I mean you know
everyone's different and I think if
you're from those areas you can be close
to home and so get work and pad your
resume so i think for certain people
it's a great strategy and there's a lot
of good stuff down there and you'll meet
a lot of interesting people so I think
that's that is a good strategy i just
think i like New Yorkers I like the city
and I like the challenge of it and I
know a lot of people there which is nice
but to have a good teacher too but I
think yeah it's great you know if you
want to be in those regional parts of
America and I think you'll also see a
part of if you want who the LA
eventually i think it's it's good to be
in those parts of America because you'll
if you're from LA maybe you'll just see
a side of America that you won't
necessarily see in Los Angeles more
normal people more gritty people more
working class and all that jazz right so
it it sounds like it's not so much the
place anymore it's just what do you want
to do and where do you want to be
because there's it sounds like there's
opportunities many places I really it's
not in some ways I they still tend to
cast the principal's out of New York and
Los Angeles you know most of the in the
secondary markets mostly if your local
it's mostly day players or small parts
it's rare that you go up for a lead but
still if you want to get experience and
then go out to LA in New York it's a
good strategy yeah I'm thinking of like
winners bone like I read seemed like a
lot of people except for Jennifer
Lawrence and a few other characters dale
dickey they were all based from where
was Missouri year ya sorry an what was
was Jennifer Lawrence living in la at
that time or was she more like I wasn't
she like blue collar comedy for like 1
over that was it the bill Engvall show
like it was some kind of show like that
I think she started on before and she
had a small part before winter's bone
fry I think she where is she living uh
yeah I'm not sure I should know this wow
this is terrible well that's okay well
look it up afterward but yeah that's
okay I think I think she's rich she's ok
now yeah she's good but but I'm just
thinking of a movie like that or there's
there's other films where you can feel
the authenticity of the place you can
yeah that people like movies like that
like are like beasts of the southern
wild and all those none of those people
were actors too and they were great you
know because they weren't trying to be
anything they were just them and yeah
that's a that's a movie like that well
you can see it in the extras even too
just you just see that maybe they're not
as concerned with being seen and this is
no offense to like la extras but
definitely if anybody's been done extra
work on a set you know people definitely
want they want to do that cross in front
of the camera and it's it's a huge thing
for them but a lot of times those
regional film shoots you can definitely
feel just more real people that are less
concerned with screen time it seems like
that's why a lot of I think directors
particularly foreign ones like to use
non-actors like there's a great the
Gospel according to st. Matthew Pier
Paolo Pasolini which is my favorite he
made that it's my favorite biblical film
which is interesting considering was
made by a gay communist atheist but he
filmed it in the south of Italy and
everyone in that movie was just people
from the country I think there were a
couple cameos my famous Italian artists
like Jesus was a Spanish economic
student and the he castings he wanted
that authenticity and it feels so
authentic like they just feel and it was
shot in black and white hand held that
just feels like they're kind of local
people who just live out in the wild who
were just being with Jesus so it just
feels very authentic well your dad is
also a director do you feel that one day
you'll also want to direct yeah I think
I could I mean I'd really really really
really want to study it cuz there's just
so much you gotta do there's so many
elements you got to think of I mean it's
like sculpture later you know we got to
think about sound and the framing and
then there's you know production time
and then just the way you direct the
actors that they're so so many elements
and you have to be good at everything
it's like an MMA fight you got to be
good at boxing and jiu jitsu and
kickboxing and dirty boxing and and
wrestling you just got to be good at all
those areas so as a director you're
really going to know your and I'd
like to someday you would okay and
lastly um even though you're in New York
and you do audition do you ever do taped
audition of the subject yeah and how is
that for you would is there someone
reading with you do you have a bad I
always
get someone to read me it can be hard
you know it's a weird feeling when like
you're not because with normal auditions
like you have a place to go like you
know there's going to be people in the
room and it's going to happen on this
day and this time so yes everything's
very definite with a self taped you know
you don't have any professional people
there with you you got to do it on your
own time and sort of that all yourself
so it is a lot of pressure on yourself
and it can be hard to make it not feel
too casual and but you got to learn how
to do it so in some sense is it almost
easier if you don't have any other
distractions because then you can really
be present like if your reader is
someone that you're comfortable with do
you think you could almost do sometimes
a better job I don't know I kind of I'll
i prefer having a definite time in place
and like being able to prepare myself
before i go in i actually will sell tape
there's more distractions because i feel
like i know exactly what's going to be
in this room when i go into an audition
for everyone's different of course for
me with a self taped eye and say if i do
it at my house it's like I got to make
sure my roommates are quiet or if I'm
doing someone else's place like it's
like we got to make sure that there's
what if people are working around
outside or something and it's like oh
I'll put it off till tomorrow because I
gotta do these emails so I feel like I
have more distractions that I don't have
a set time in a set date interesting so
it's better to have to have a time place
and a structure to it for me okay Jason
would have been your strategy in seeking
out acting teachers or coaches well I
didn't have one for a while after school
because I was second myself I've had
three years of people telling me what to
do and how to act and I learned a lot to
get me wrong but I thought I want to
kind of be myself for a while and then I
didn't get anything for a while and I
was just trying to figure out how to
live by my lonesome out of college and
then earlier this year I I just thought
you know what I think it's time I start
an acting class again even if just to
have a place where I can do it every
week so that I'm obligated to act every
single week and I'm keeping it sharp you
know it's like as an act if your workout
you got to work
every week unless maybe you've had a
bunch you got to have a deal owed week
that's a different topic and so and I
was quite I lucked out actually because
I've been writing down a lot of acting
teachers in schools I was planning on
trying out a lot of them but I had a
friend who I he just told me about this
acting teacher he had and I thought oh
I'll let her see how I like her and I
went to her apartment and she
interviewed me to see if I was right for
her class and I just got this this vibe
from her like I was like I click with
this person this person speaks my
language and I like the way they look at
it and I think we're good match and she
was making all these observations about
me that I didn't know you could make if
he didn't know me for a long time and
I'm not talking cold reading
i'm talking like real deep observations
and so I started going to her class and
for now I'm just sticking it with her I
mean maybe a long while in the future I
might try out some other stuff at a dude
thing you got to expose yourself to
different people but for now i'm content
being with this person so it sounds like
you took a break because you were so it
was so intensive when you were at lambda
and then you just wanted to do some
stuff on your own and you realize that
just finding someone that intuitively
you matched with mm-hmm was probably the
best thing it wasn't necessarily a style
right Meisner or oh yeah she kind of has
her own way of working the cheese
derived from various people she's worked
with cheese Russian Jewish and pretty
old she met Turkish key andrei tarkovsky
the famous Russian director and like
she's so she's been around uh-huh and
she she was taught by some people who
were Michael Chekov students she might
have had a teacher too who was a
Stanislavski student from like directly
from him there's one guy in particular
who she really really likes so it was
one of Stanislavski students who
Stanislavski said it was a better
teacher than him and I think she was
taught by a couple of Meyer hold
students as well so a lot of the rush a
lot of the Russians she likes but also
her own methods from various people
she's worked with and practices and so
your advice to another young actor out
of school sounds like find somebody that
you just really resonate with as a
person uh-huh yeah and like don't be
afraid to try different people and ask
them questions and uh if you feel like
their answer doesn't make sense to you
then then move on and I also say when
you're looking for a teacher you're
don't look for someone who you think is
just going to make you good right away
will just get you famous or get you work
right away you know it's a process you
know this is not a get-rich-quick scheme
you know look for someone who is going
to challenge you and and and work
because I think a lot of people just
want to start getting work right away
which is fine don't deny it if it comes
but you know not everyone's ready right
away and you just got to really be
confident what you're doing before you
start trying to get everyone to like you
it's not it's not a weekend real estate
course no okay yeah you want to make
sure that you feel comfortable there and
what if someone let's say they don't
they've been in the class a little bit
and there's just something or they just
don't feel right one should they make
that break and go to another one
wouldn't know everyone else likes it
like when you when you can you know be
polite about it don't burn a bridge
don't don't insult them or anything but
just say you know i'm i'm still trying
to figure out who i am as an actor and
i'm trying to maybe try different people
and and just see what happens and i just
want to see what else there is out there
I think if they're any good or if
they're any if they have any
understanding they don't understand that
you know they understand and like you
got to find your own path and find
resonates with you as long as you're
respectful about it and you just say I'm
just trying to see what else is out
there you know if you're a dick about it
you just say you suck of course they're
not going to they're going to be angry
at you so did ya just use prudence I'd
say but don't don't ever stick with some
I mean don't leave just because you're
feeling like it's harder because it's
challenged you know i'd say give it a
good go before you really decide that
it's not right for you because who knows
maybe at first you're it doesn't feel
right just
you're being challenged or maybe you're
just being put out of your comfort zone
but after a while if you really don't
think you're getting results then you
know then try something else